j'ai compris
pourquoi je vous arrête mon téléphone
on peut nous raconter excusez-moi vous
savez pourquoi on vous arrête
non j'ai pas mis clignotant pour passer
sur
l'appareil et vous viendrez le récupérer
ce soir au commissariat vous allez me
donner votre téléphone parce qu'on
l'aurait été sélectionné vous le
récupérer ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je viens de l'avoir depuis hier
on confisque les téléphones
pour moi
pour le récupérer ce soir à Melun et
sinon oui et sinon dans 15 jours parce
que là il y a le pont là
mon copain aussi il faut lui donner
effectivement sensibilisé à
l'interdiction etc
d'être effectivement en situation de non
circulation avec mon engin et aussi
problème de m'arrêter et de me garer et
de faire mes petites affaires je
comprends rien j'ai décroché
bonne journée
soyons clairs vous êtes arrivés vous
êtes au téléphone vous avez pas de
ceinture vous avez pas de soutien-gorge
qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous on vous arrête
mais qu'est-ce
que vous soutien-gorge ça me regarde
j'ai la poitrine qui tient heureusement
je suis jeune
avec moi je viens de me faire des
panason
courrier je suis d'accord avec eux je
peux pas la mettre sur le pare-brise
parce que je l'ai pas reçu
qui la donne qui la donne bah oui bah je
l'ai pas reçu par la poste le verbe
recevoir
et vous avez le reçu ou pas vous avez
pas la presse
vous êtes père ou le contraire donc
voilà
mais je suis content c'est un stylo s'il
vous plaît
genre tout de suite la pastille la
voiture la moins d'un an du genre il
faut une passible sur la voiture et que
si elle est dans la minute qu'on nous
demande ça et vous êtes tous les deux là
comme ça les gens tous les deux vous
allez me bloquer la voiture vous croyez
quoi moi franchement je m'arrache non
non non attendez monsieur vous faites un
PV sur moi je veux pas perdre de temps
vous faites un peu vite je m'arrache
hein
ça marche pas il est vert en plus ouais
il est vert non voilà
je vais la chercher tout de suite
[Musique]
quand il pleut c'est un père et quand il
fait beau c'est super voilà c'est bon
mais vous pouvez y aller alors c'est bon
mais n'oubliez pas de la coller la
prochaine fois
vous prenez un petit peu de peinture
chez vous vous faites un petit rond vert
ça le fait
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur vous coupez le moteur
s'il vous plaît contrôle papier s'il
vous plaît confirmation du dépassement
de la limite de vitesse du
véhiculeur rouge
255 92 12
km/h elle était flashé à 82
84 km/h monsieur
mais c'est moi qui je sais même plus où
est mon permis là là je suis sidéré là
mais j'ai pas vu 92 km/h c'est pas
possible je vais tout doucement c'est la
loi la nouvelle loi on prend les permis
immédiatement et puis voilà et
voilà hop
allez hop
tiens là
vous allez le repasser donc il vous sert
plus rien mais vous avez peut-être
besoin de la photo il faut sortir du
véhicule maintenant puisque vous avez
plus de vous avez pu le permis
vous êtes obligé
ça fait mal en plus c'est juste
merci au revoir
tu nous laisses pas la musique
alors le métro le plus proche
continuer le shooter
bonjour monsieur simple contrôle
anti-pollution vous laissez le moteur
allumé nous allons vous mettre une sonde
dans le pot d'accord
1740 1740
immobilisation je fais une réquisition
du véhicule
c'est une immobilisation pour pollution
déménagement
et vous la récupérez dans quoi dans une
petite semaine
j'habite pas loin j'habite à Colombes ah
bah voilà comme ça vous pouvez rentrer à
pied
c'est parce que j'attendais là justement
je viens de recevoir le message
alors les papiers
c'est ça on l'a dit les portables on en
reparle
je me suis fait gauler par un flic qui
était un peu sur les nerfs parce que moi
mon portable est tout le temps en panne
ça m'énerve
vous avez été flashé là-bas à 60 km
[Musique]
et puis on en parle plus faites-moi 10
pompes et on en parle plus
sinon c'est un PV à 560 balles
1 2
4 5
8 9 et 10 voilà je ne dépasserai pas la
vitesse d'accord je ne dépasserai pas la
vitesse je le jure je le jure merci
monsieur l'agent merci Monsieur allez
c'est bon non non je voulais
pas question ça se fait pas ça mais si
ça se fait pas mais si ça se trouve pas
mais si ça se fait maintenant ça se fait
j'ai pas entendu la loi vous faites voir
la loi vous me faites voir l'arrêter
c'est vous là
il faut que j'aille chercher mes gosses
j'ai besoin d'une voiture
j'ai compris
pas vraiment parce que j'ai mon petit
cousin qui passe le bac là je vais
prêter un Toky pour l'aider un petit
coup ça fait rire
et en trigonométrie mais c'est quoi là
c'est parce qu'il a des épreuves il est
en train de passer là j'ai un petit
micro émetteur et là j'ai une oreillette
et j'entends tout ce qu'il me dit et ça
c'est de la magouille qui de la poule ou
de l'œuf est arrivé en premier
c'est la logique
ah ben non autant pour moi c'est l'oeuf
c'est l'oeuf parce que oui c'est l'œuf
évidemment mais c'est le alors il
faudrait je sais pas comment tourner ça
par contre
[Musique]
messieurs
les connaissez en philo un petit peu qui
de la poule de la ceinture déjà
qui de la poule ou de l'œuf est arrivé
en premier
très franchement
très franchement je sais pas monsieur
je vais être obligé de vous compter la
ceinture alors il faut qu'il explique
que c'est par la
poupe et qu'évidemment la poule est
arrivée également par là donc ben non
c'est execo c'est
le Big Bang ah le Big Bang quand il y a
eu le big bang pour il y a une poule
directement c'est vrai
et après il y en a juste une petite
après c'est à partir de combien est-ce
de trop
je l'ai su en plus
un train à part d'un point B à 16h30 il
met 45 minutes pour arriver à quelle
heure il arrivera donc si je réponds je
vais avoir une deuxième contravention
parce que la première je vais la voir là
tu t'y connais en lettres toi ouais
voyelle
B consonne
CC et voyelle
e
puisque ceux que je foute avec ça
pas mieux
OK
il peut régler tout de suite si vous
voulez ça fait moins cher
bien 150
annulation de l'enlèvement demandé
non le monsieur s'arrange à l'amiable ok
bien reçu je vais demander de la monnaie
au bureau voilà
montrez-moi les papiers qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire nous commençons qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire montrez-moi les papiers du
véhicule
voilà merci c'est bien gentil allez-y
filet oui bah voilà je l'ai déchiré
allez au revoir monsieur
la façon dont on avait parlé j'ai pas du
tout apprécié qu'est-ce que je vous
avais dit
qu'est-ce que je vous avais dit moi
je connais je suis bien placé
là vous êtes mal garés
c'est quoi ce permis
parce que c'est celui de du monsieur
d'avance c'est un faux
mais non alors
tu vas prendre plein ta tête toi
vous êtes un mal
la voiture
vous êtes illogique vous êtes garé comme
un cochon
j'ai pas dit que vous étiez un cochon
alors
on va prendre un autre animal alors un
cheval vous êtes garé comme un cheval
sortez du véhicule
il y a pas de raison que je sois sous la
pluie et pas vous
alors
interdit les portables sur la plage
parce que ça fait chier tout le monde ça
fait chier
pourquoi vous êtes en train de
téléphoner vous venez le récupérer au
commissariat
[Musique]
pour récupérer ou pas
voilà d'accord
[Musique]
voilà comme ça on l'entend plus
je vais le téléphone à la télé parce que
je travaille à la télé je vais leur
téléphoner pour leur dire comment
comment ils accueillent les touristes
ici vous le prenez comme ça voilà alors
votre portable voilà non non
[Musique]
moi aussi je vais le dire à la télé on a
rien fait
alors je je je
ne le
je ne
m'excuse monsieur ça veut rien dire
[Musique]
ça fait des ça fait des inter des
interférences sur le sur le système de
navigation et donc comme il y a marée
basse vous voyez vous vous venez au
commissariat alors de suite alors parce
que moi je finis ma ronde je finis à 19h
que des enfants
qui sortent du casino qui roulent
en Ferrari
voilà maintenant vous pouvez le déclarer
vous avez pas le droit de faire ça vous
avez le droit vous de partir je vous ai
dit de partir
[Musique]
vous allez le déclarer noyer c'est pas
frais
j'ai toutes mes cartes commerciales qui
sont avec ce table non c'est pas un
jetable
et il savait pas nager
dans le quartier toi tu es arrivé à ta
casquette
une seconde je suis avec Monsieur là
je te demande un renseignement tu me le
donnes connard sale flic [__] que je te
chope dans le quartier toi
on est plus en sécurité
beaucoup beaucoup de vols
tu peux me répondre
qu'est-ce que vous voulez vous voulez
que j'appelle des collègues et qu'on
vous embarque
si tu as des couilles tu es qu'une merde
non pas du tout
pardon
oui attendez je suis avec Monsieur
que je te croise pas dans le quartier
[Musique]
j'aime pas ça
quand même tu me réponds
pas ça des impôts qu'on paye sur la
présence
la police on peut pas appeler la police
c'est moi la police monsieur
je te demande connard je te pose une
question
il est servi à lui répondre monsieur
connard là
[Musique]